let me just bring you some breaking news
coming into us via West Midlands police
and it's concerning at the deaths of
children on that frozen lake
um and we are hearing now from West
Midlands police they say that it's with
heartfelt sadness that we have to report
this afternoon at the six-year-old in
hospital has lost his fight for life our
deepest sympathies with the families and
friends
of those involved in this tragedy West
Midland Police go on to say we can't
comprehend the enormity of the pain they
must feel and our hearts go out to them
specialist officers remain in contact
with the family and we will issue
further information as soon as we can
they go on to say that these searches
have been completed and the Sea at the
scene of the incident at the lake and
those searches will be lifted this
evening so that's just news just in
following that tragic situation at the
lake near solihull
we have had an update from police to say
that with heartfelt sadness they say in
their statement that they are reporting
this afternoon that the six-year-old
who'd been taken to hospital has lost
his fight for life